throughout european history there have
been many attempts to reform the
calendar perhaps the most famous was
during the french revolution where its
leaders opted to change the calendar to
something less religiony but one attempt
that's less well known was when the
government of the ussr adopted a
reformed gregorian calendar in 1929
which changed the seven-day week to a
five-day one and later into a six-day
week this calendar was changed back to
the same one that the rest of the
western world used in 1940 which raises
the question why why did the soviet
calendar fail when the russian
revolution was over and the previous
government was unavailable lenin and his
comrades sought to reform the way that
society worked and one of their first
acts was to move away from the old
julian calendar yet in the late 1920s
soviet ministers were concerned that
there wasn't enough work going on in the
workers state the problem was that those
who were doing their work were quite
fond of things like having sundays off
and given the soviet leadership dislike
of all things religious something had to
be done one of the long-standing
proposals had been to radically reform
the calendar this was largely ridiculed
because it was seen as being excessive
and also very difficult to implement
that was until stalin came across the
idea and gave it his approval at which
point it probably became the greatest
idea since some german fellow wrote a
pamphlet and so with this the top minds
of the ussr came up with a brand new
calendar one in which there were five
days in a week and six weeks in a month
across these five days one-fifth of its
workforce would have a different day off
months with 31 days would see a six-day
work week and everybody got five
national holidays off this way workers
would be more rested than the previous
one in seven days they had off employers
would also have 80 of their workforce
available at all times and sundays would
importantly be robbed of their religious
significance in 1929 and 1930 the new
calendar was brought in across numerous
industries importantly this new calendar
wasn't meant to replace the gregorian
calendar that most people used this new
one was just used alongside it so people
would know when they were working so why
did the ussr get rid of it well there
were numerous problems the first was
that sundays had previously been used to
repair machinery and catch up on any
unfinished work in the previous week
which thus could no longer be done
another problem was that many people
became disgruntled since their days off
and those of their friends and families
didn't match up as such the central
government came up with a new idea the
six day week this meant that everybody
would do more work and furthermore an
employer would give everybody the 6th
the 12th the 18th the 24th and the 30th
of every month off this didn't fix all
of the problems and combined with the
fact that many industries hadn't really
adopted the calendar at all stalin opted
to abandon the idea in 1940. everybody
returned to the seven-day work week and
employers were free to give people
whichever days off they wanted so long
as they met their targets that is
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly money maker sky
chappelle caution wolf jerry landon
jordan longley adam stalter marcus asner
wyan hockey spencer lightfoot rod d
martin words about books podcast captain
cydog gustav swan marvin castle common
yoon winston k wood bugilly wiggly
daniel to be in miss iset aaron the
white corey turner the mcwhopper alex
schwinn anthony beckett coppertone
maggie patzkowski schuenin spinning
three plates and charles the first